Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
so I know you notice something my voice
is a little deep and it's a little
hoarse because I kind of throw up my
voice yesterday and la collaboration was
pretty dope but check it out so we have
met it's the Sun coming out again
because it just got a little brighter
those of you who do not know what people
say there is people's hater is a way for
me to go ahead and give back to your
home if you had somebody in your past
that he's either done you're wrong did
you dirty I don't know did some of you
that let me go ahead and verbally abuse
it for you so in order for y'all to be
on the peoples hater this is how you're
gonna do it number one go to my facebook
fan page and tell me the story then do I
read every single story yes I do I do be
them so just remember you go ahead and
like the page and if you've already
liked it then you can already go ahead
and submit your story number two
remember when you tell your story make
sure it does not go above five to six
sentences because the last time I did
this some of y'all went back to the very
beginning of your lives where the Thor
begins when I was a fetus in my mama's
womb I need you to fast forward a little
bit I do not need to hear the story of
Noah's Ark number three danger submit
your story is gonna be November 8th and
November 8th alone so only on November
8th remember only on November 8th so
those are the rules people remember to
abide by all of those rules if you do
not you cannot win this I know this is
so stupid because it's not an actual
prize but it is something that help
yourself it'll help your heart no it's a
thing David how dare you waste a video
whatever so you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna show you guys a little
something about myself that I didn't
want to then I wasn't gonna release but
I'm gonna show you anyways just when I
went hiking that's right
I worked out so you don't see what I
look like when I work out now and join
[ __ ] see this YouTube this is
what I do for you I'm an animal I'll
survive this let it got past four people
have passed us up these two bastards up
there showing off Nick better than me
huh cuz you climb up mountains
YouTube I'm not sure if you see this but
in the distance there are vultures you
have vultures do vultures eat dead
bodies I am moving I'm under boob sweat
there's nothing here technology I knew I
was gonna make it I never doubted myself
for a minute so sexy downhill is my
forte skill downhill so fast watch this
mess them up the hell with this downhill
crap oh oh [ __ ] oh I almost fell this is
some Lewis and card [ __ ] Tom Sawyer
as climbing mountain river going there's
no God do I look like a [ __ ] settler
to you
where is this right now are we even
going oh my god is it natural for that
to be sharp pain in my side sharp pain
in my side I'm a little bit